most of you have probably heard by now
that we are facing a big big revenue
shortfall roughly 40 depending on the
month forty to fifty five percent of our
revenue has been crushed taken out at
the knees for lack of a better term
because of a YouTube advertiser boycott
where ads have effectively stopped
playing on all the videos on our YouTube
channel fourteen thousand videos one day
last week or the week before we had
nearly half a million views in a day and
the youtube channel made 34 cents 34
cents 34 cents doesn't go too far in
terms of covering all the production
costs of the show so i i'm thrilled to
say that people have been saying David
how worried are you about this are you
guys making up some of the revenue part
of the revenue none of it all of it up
through our patreon.com slash david
pakman show platform we are starting to
make headway here and we're making up
lost revenue and if you have even just a
dollar to throw in as you can see here
it's as simple as going to
patreon.com/scishow and hitting that big
orange orange or red what do you call
that color pad I call that orange I say
that's orange yeah red is the YouTube
logo right you hit the orange become a
patron button and if it's a buck a month
two dollars a month five dollars a month
it all helps and I've said this before
and I'll say it again it doesn't take
much to make up for the lost YouTube
revenue individually in the sense that
we used to get about a fifth of a penny
a fifth of a penny for each ad that you
would watch before a video so if you
watched all 160 roughly videos that we
do in a month you would send us anywhere
from 30 to 50 Cent's ok by donating a
dollar a month you're doubling or
tripling what you were likely
contributing to us if you can do two
bucks a month you are by orders of
magnitude making up for the lost revenue
that you as an individual viewer we're
able to bring to us so this is one of
those areas where I know people often
when they hear a pitch like this pat
they say aunt dollar-a-month doesn't do
anything i'm sure most people or a lot
of people are already donating we
estimate that only one
of our audience is contributing
financially be part of the push towards
three percent okay if we can move our
audience to wear three percent of our
audience is contributing financially the
YouTube crisis is no longer a crisis
it's something we can laugh at and say
we no longer have to give you know what
a flying you know what about what's
monetized and what isn't because we've
exceeded and gone above and beyond
replacing that revenue even if you can
just contribute a dollar too so
complacency this is sort of a call to
say be the person who just contributes
the dollar because if everybody says I
don't I don't not going to wonder
whether everybody else is going to do it
I'll just contribute a dollar or two and
I've done my part then we solve this
problem yeah these big goals take a
whole village to accomplish in a little
bit it takes a village I like that so
patreon.com slash david pakman show
there are three big ways actually that
you can support the work we're doing
patreon is one of them here's the list
though of the three things that you can
do number one is membership at david
pakman.com slash membership number two
is patreon patreon.com slash david
pakman show number three is before you
do any amazon shopping go to david
pakman.com slash amazon it'll redirect
you to amazon five to eight percent of
your purchase comes back to us and
thanks to everybody who's already
contributed